blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
david pakman so we haven't talked about
vaccination for a while and you know
generally speaking i've been aware that
the us has vaccinated about 60 percent
overall
and i intuitively assumed that there was
some kind of partisan split because of
some of the numbers we've been looking
at but i did not realize how
disturbingly horrible the partisan gap
is so let's go through what we've known
for a while
we've known for a while that there was
probably some partisan split on
vaccination
we've seen that for the greater part of
2021
coveted cases hospitalizations and
deaths have been disproportionately
happening in the reddest red trump
counties compared to
the bluest blue
biden counties
we've seen how the covet death rate
since vaccines have been widely
available is about three times higher in
the reddest trump counties compared to
the bluest biden counties and again this
came with the intuition that part of the
explanation must be vaccination rates
now i also have said
even in blue counties it's likely that
the deaths are still skewing towards
republicans relative to that county's
population we now have data on
vaccination and it is even worse than i
imagined at this point in time
96
of democrats
say they've already been vaccinated
while only 54 percent of republicans
have been vaccinated there is no
uh there is no lesser vaccinated group
than republicans at this point in time
in the united states democrats are
getting vaccinated
at nearly twice the rate of republicans
this is no small detail
this is from polling done by monmouth
university let's take a look at the
numbers in more detail so you see the
clear partisan divide
96 percent of democrats have been
vaccinated
79 of independents have been vaccinated
and a pathetic
54. of republicans have been vaccinated
now just as interestingly
30 percent of republicans say they will
never
get the vaccine
another interesting thing
those who are not registered to vote
actually got vaccinated at a slightly
higher rate than those who are
registered to vote that's interesting
also along educational lines there is a
gap
87 percent of those with a four-year
degree
have been vaccinated only 73
of those without a four-year degree
have been vaccinated so
not a big shock education leads to
vaccination just like education tends to
lead to people being more liberal voting
more for democrats than from republicans
now interestingly there's almost no
income gap whatsoever
you might speculate you might not i
don't know but you might speculate that
among different income groups you would
see vaccination at different levels the
vaccine is free at the end user point
but maybe there would be some reason why
you'd see different levels of vaccine
uptake based on income we don't see that
you make under 50k a year 78 have been
vaccinated if you make between 50 and
100k a year 77 have been vaccinated i
mean almost an identical number those
making over 100k a year 79 have been
vaccinated i mean essentially no impact
on vaccination status based on income so
really interesting numbers and also just
stunningly low republican vaccination so
at this point i don't know that the
republican party cares about the
personal tragedy the fact that way more
of their people are dying than others i
mean after all it's all humans right
maybe they care maybe they don't i don't
know
politically
this will mean fewer republicans around
and alive to vote in the midterms
particularly since it's
disproportionately voting age people
that are dying as a result of the virus
now republicans will still have
gerrymandering working for them uh
republicans will still have voter
suppression
they'll have you know trying to use the
courts all these different things that
we've seen them now try to do
but there will be disproportionately
fewer of them could it affect close
races it's still really not clear you
know we ran the numbers i'm going from
memory now but we ran the numbers
looking at ron desantis's last
gubernatorial win in florida he's the
very trumpian republican governor of
florida uh i i hope i'm getting this
right i think desantis won by about 30
something thousand votes
and when we looked at the deaths in
florida and started to say okay if these
are 60 40
republican deaths if these are 65 35
republican deaths could it make a
difference in the next gubernatorial
election and the answer is it could it's
not a open and shut case
there
there's a lot of caveats but the point
is it's conceivable that the math would
point that way on on partisan
death gap alone
you could see a case made that it could
lose the florida governorship for
republicans so if that's conceivably
possible certainly there are
congressional districts where the death
gap on covid could make a difference
whether they care about the people i
don't know but you'd think they would at
least care about elections
so earlier this week we kind of hit oan
pretty hard
because they deserve it oan is this
wacky right-wing propaganda network and
i i think i said in the segment fox news
is right-wing propaganda
news max is extreme right-wing
propaganda and oan is like completely
insane right-wing propaganda and i even
said
compared to oan
newsmax sometimes will sound sort of a
little bit reasonable today i have an
example of newsmax not sounding even at
all reasonable and this is a really
instructive segment i'm going to play
for you one of the most hilariously and
horrifyingly
ignorant segments that i've ever seen i
would say on any network i i don't know
that i've ever seen
a one minute segment with such ignorance
there's a news max host named chris
salcedo salcedo
i actually think i've been on his show
before i re if i'm thinking of the same
guy he used to have a radio show
maybe philly i don't remember
i think the interview i did with him on
his radio show might even be on our
website in the press section from what i
recall
he was much less ignorant back then the
ignorance was less weaponized although
it was still bad i don't know if what
i'm about to play for you are his
genuine views or what he has to do to be
on the good boy list at oan but he went
on a rant yesterday climate change
denial ran
i can't make heads or tails out of it
i don't know how someone can be this
dumb and again he might not be dumb this
might just be over propaganda
it's like brain rot of some kind like
his his head is filled with mayonnaise
or
honey mustard or something it's almost
like his brain fell out of his head so
let me play the clip
listen to the mind-blowingly ignorant
and incorrect things that he says here
and then we're going to break it down
piece by piece as to the science of the
socialist religion
from experts i have read and interviewed
over the years i can say that there is
no proof that man's co2 emissions are
destroying the planet if that were the
case the world would have invaded
communist china long ago they build one
so-called dirty coal-fired plant on
average every week
if china's co2 emissions were destroying
all life on mother earth
and china is the world's number one co2
emitter
why would obama biden and the rest of
the american left leave china alone and
instead destroy the united states
manufacturing base and our energy
production
joe biden claims that warmer
temperatures make weather more
destructive that has not been proven
what has been proven is that warmer
weather results in more food production
less starvation and less death
what has been proven is that the earth
has been at this temperature before back
in the medieval period not too many coal
plants and suvs trolling around at that
time right
so you you really have to
slow down
and think about each aspect of this one
at a time
the mind-blowing stupidity
is notable
but the wildest aspect is he almost
seems like proud that he's saying this
stuff
on tv
he genuinely seems to think it's clever
so let's go through it piece by piece
he talks about science the socialists
religion
you can make the case that sometimes
people
allow dogmatism
to enter their view of science and when
that happens we should criticize it
but science is not a religion and when
when people say science is your religion
you can believe in christianity or you
can believe in science that's very much
wrong because science exists and is the
same regardless of whether you believe
in it or not nobody believed in
christianity christianity disappears
right uh science encourages being
corrected fixing mistakes
and has self-correction mechanisms and
in fact when you make the the bigger the
correction you make in science the
bigger the accolades the more revered
you are religion doesn't have that
uh self-correction is not revered in
religion uh so
these analogies science is the religion
of socialists maybe there's some
dogmatic people when it comes to science
is very very different than a religion
he says experts that i've read and
interviewed say there's no proof that
co2 from man is destroying the planet
it's always hyperbolic and there's
always some semantic game right so okay
well destroying the planet is a big
statement the scientific consensus is
very clear that elevated co2
caused by industrial activity now if you
would they say well humans didn't do
that the factories did it that's a
distinction without a difference
that is bad for the planet in many ways
its effect on climate
its effect on the ozone layer
accelerating the greenhouse effect this
is the scientific consensus could it be
wrong it could
many people right now are trying to
disprove it none have been able to so
far it remains the best explanation we
have right now that's how science works
um he says if co2 were really this bad
we would have invaded communist china by
now you know the issue of china's
pollution is a huge topic in and of
itself and it kind of exceeds our scope
today but it is absurdly simplistic to
say if co2 were really bad we would
invade china it's so dumb it's kind of
hard to refute adults don't really think
in this way he then argues that co2
emissions
uh aren't really destroying all life on
earth
well we're not saying that that's what
it is it's sort of again that the
argument isn't all life on earth today
is being destroyed by co2 it's a straw
man or a red herring
he argues that warmer temperatures are
good
because if it's warmer
you get more food growth
that's really complicated but understand
that when it's unseasonably warm
if you don't have more rain to go with
it you get drought and drought is not
good for crops it kills crops or you've
got to go and find more water to raise
the same amount of food that's also not
good for the environment so warmer being
better for food production also not true
uh and then he says earth has been at
this temperature before before we had
modern industry that's true there have
been periods of warming on earth before
uh but temperatures are only one part of
what's going on co2 in the atmosphere
has never been this high that's a big
piece of it the fact that it's been worn
before doesn't prove or disprove
anything so it took me what seven
minutes
this is like two plus two equals five
type of stuff and it takes a while to
disprove it sam harris said and on this
he's completely right
it's very easy to start a series of
small fires
that are really time consuming to put
out it's much easier to start the fires
than to put them out and unfortunately
whether chris salcedo believes this
stuff or he knows he's just feeding his
audience the drivel and pablum that they
so desperately want uh some of his
audience falls for it and believes it
and now we're sitting here trying to
undo it really really bad and i mean
it's like like his brain left his his
cranium really scary stuff uh we have a
uh we have two things going on number
one
the town hall rescheduled for december
28th due to technical difficulties 6 p.m
december 28th i hope you'll join us
it'll definitely be the last one of the
year also january 1st we'll be doing a
one-day membership bomb
kicking off an election year with a huge
membership discount i would love for you
to participate all you need to do today
is sign up for my mailing list at
davidpakman.com and then on the first
you'll be notified about exactly how to
avail yourself of this incredible
membership discount
one of our sponsors is blinkist who's
been supporting the david pakman show
longer than any other sponsor blinkist
is the app that lets you listen to or
read an entire non-fiction book in just
15 minutes blinkist is the way to absorb
those books you can't make time for
blinkist takes top non-fiction titles
pulls out the book's key takeaways and
insights and gives it to you in the form
of a text or audio explainer that you
can consume in 15 minutes with blinkist
now you actually do have time to learn
about all the things you've been wanting
to tackle on the blinkist app i just
listened to this is your mind on plants
by the great michael pollan
super interesting the history of
caffeine and so many other things
blinkist has you covered on podcast 2.
blinkist takes long episodes of popular
podcasts and distills them into audio
you can listen to in 15 minutes with
blinkist you can become knowledgeable
about so many different things you can
have conversations with people about
more topics blinkist makes you more
well-rounded try blinkist for free and
get 25 off a subscription go to
blinkist.com
david pakman the link is down below all
right remember that the david pakman
show it depends on your support uh you
can sign up at joinpacman.com we do an
extra show every day for our members
called the bonus show you can get access
to it simply by signing up at
joinpakman.com also we include
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show
all of it available at a very very low
rate uh you can sign up at
joinpakman.com and use the coupon code
better21
to uh shave a pretty solid portion off
of that encourage you to do that you can
also join the discussion on the david
pakman show subreddit that's at
davidpakman.com
r-e-d-d-i-t-n
34 000 of our viewers and listeners are
now subscribed there spotted a few
interesting posts this morning that i
wanted to talk about one user asks
does david think the word karen should
be bannable in the past he said this is
a racially charged word uh no i don't
think i mean listen bannable by who we
don't ban people for using it what i've
said before is
i
make every effort not to use
any words
that are pejoratives
grouping people by race and while
i don't know if it's explicit or not
karen is essentially a pejorative about
entitled white women
and so i see no reason to use the term
it's conceivable that
it may have gotten into a youtube title
or two a while ago
uh but i've stopped using it and as an
editorial thing i i i don't think it's
particularly useful
the question about bands i think is
related to recently
there was this big dust up on twitch
where two streamers that are kind of in
our universe hassan [ __ ] and ian vosh
were banned for using the word
i mean i i guess i have to be careful
it's a word you know saltines would be
in this category
um
[Music]
cheez-its would be in this category it's
a pejorative for white people
they were banned and a bunch of people
on the left kind of came out defending
it saying the word isn't really racially
charged
um i see it as racially charged and so
my take was
again i don't think it's really a word
progressive should use it's a it's a
pejorative about white people if you
think about the word it doesn't apply
you don't think about asians when the
word is said you don't think about
native americans it's about white people
i avoid pejoratives that group people by
race now you know
twitch bands in terms of service i don't
know i think it's all kind of dumb but
the point is if you're banned for using
the n-word it's not shocking that you
would be banned for using a pejorative
about white people even if they don't
have the same historical weight which
they don't uh and i admit so that's my
view about karen that's my view about
the c word the n word etc um another
post that i spotted biden official warns
covet explosion imminent yeah so listen
there's there's bad news and then
there's maybe okay news when it comes to
covet i've not been covering the
day-to-day of the omicron variant
because information is changing so
quickly if we look at the uk right now
they are seeing record cases it's wild
what's going on in the uk that being
said the uk is doing a lot of testing
and the data we have right now
still points to
omicron being more mild is it as mild as
the flu which is about a fifth as deadly
as the original covet strains we don't
know should people still get vaccinated
and boosted yes
uh absolutely
should the immunocompromised and others
take serious precautions yes
but
the potentially less bad thing is that
at the individual level
omicron may be milder and it continues
to to point that way the problem is
you have to remember
as an individual if omicron is more mild
if you get it you're less likely to be
seriously ill at the population level
if it's significantly more contagious
even though any one person's odds are
getting really sick or lower it'll still
fill up the hospitals and if you think
about burden of disease if it's half as
deadly but three times as contagious if
i get it it's less likely for me that it
will be serious but it's still going to
lead to way more people uh getting very
very sick so you know i'm still waiting
for something more definitive but that's
the way it looks so far
last post i spotted what is up with the
weird lighting in david's studio is it
just me or is it dimmer seems if he's
trying to switch things up now what
what's going on is i've been on the road
and our new
mechanism you know it's
the audience is very fickle and
emotional
and sometimes when it's clear that i'm
on the road and i have a different
background people get very mad i mean
it's it's crazy sometimes people get mad
that i'm doing something sometimes
people get mad that i'm not in the
studio
so for a while now when i'm on the road
i've been using a green screen and it
replicates the home studio now some
people notice i'm in a different place
because my mic is different or the
lighting's a little different or
whatever
this time around the equipment i chose
is not quite as good
so things are a little bit degraded i've
gone weeks in the past on the road and
people haven't noticed when i've had
other equipment with me this time it's
noticeable we're going to try to do
better next time
you can join the discussion at
davidpakman.com
reddit
okay it is i i don't know that i can say
it's officially the 2022 midterms right
now but at least in the context of
the former president donald trump
jumping in full steam ahead on the 2022
midterms things are getting going donald
trump has added another endorsement this
is an extremely polarizing endorsement
this is exactly the type of endorsement
we were waiting for of an incumbent
lunatic trumpian republican to show us
yes trump's going to be involved donald
trump has now endorsed radical
lunatic extremist disgusting republican
congresswoman from colorado
lauren beaubert
or lauren bo bear as ro khanna called
her i kind of liked when ro said
congresswoman beau bear
sounds like a completely different
person donald trump putting out this
endorsement laced with erratic
capitalization which i will mention
um endorsement of congresswoman lauren
bober
congresswoman lauren beaubert has done a
fantastic job in her first term
representing colorado's third district
uh i can't think of anything she's done
but okay she is a fearless leader
a defender of the capitalized america
first agenda and a fighter against the
capital l loser rhinos and capital r
radical capital d democrats she will
continue to be tough on capital c crime
strong on capital b borders and always
protect our under siege second amendment
lauren has my capital c complete and
capital t total
capital e endorsement for her
re-election
why the random capitalization we still
don't know someone wrote to me and said
oh you know trump is german
and in in german you have capitalized
nouns and that's not what trump is doing
guys i can assure you trump has no idea
what's going on in german
um so what's interesting about this okay
we suspected trump was going to be very
involved in 2022
and he's getting involved right now
lauren beaubert has actually said she
has already asked donald trump to go to
her district and do a rally for her if
trump gets involved to that level it is
going to be quite a midterm and indeed i
think it is going to be quite a midterm
also
the choice of this district is
interesting because let's be frank this
is a very easy race and trump is big on
his record now he lies about his
endorsement record trump has previously
said he's like you know
what do you say 151 or something his
record is actually not that good he
mostly endorses incumbents and still i
think he only had like a 60-something
percent
success record with endorsements but
this is a really easy one if you want to
put points on the board and then use
those points to justify
running yourself in 2024
no democrat has been uh
the representative for colorado's third
district since 2008 that was john
salazar if you go before 2008 and
remember the elections are every two
years in the house if you go before 2008
you've got to go back to 1992
for this the last democrat to hold that
seat so in other words since 1992
one democrat has held the third district
of colorado and it's otherwise all
republicans you look at the demographics
it's 65 rural
very favorable to republicans it's 71
percent white
pretty favorable uh to to republicans
although not not as crazy skewed as some
other districts it is considered in the
cook political report political values
index a republican plus six race and
when you consider other factors
including the power of incumbency that's
a pretty solid republican seat so one of
the things we will be paying attention
to is okay trump's going to be involved
he's going to be doing endorsements is
he disproportionately doing them in the
safest of safe districts he is endorsing
some challengers but is he mostly
endorsing incumbents all of this is
stuff that we're going to follow but
number one it's clear he wants to be
involved and number two these trumpian
races
may very much influence what the
republican party decides to do in 2024
and whether donald trump will even run
earlier this week we interviewed michael
cohen michael cohen said donald's not
running in 24
and he's not running because he can't
afford the hit to his ego to lose again
the counter would be and it's not about
who's right or wrong there's no right or
wrong yet because it hasn't happened
they're just predictions the counter
would be trump ends up believing he can
easily win everything and so that may be
a factor in him deciding to run but step
one is we don't even have to worry about
24 we're going to look at trump's record
in 22 we'll look at how he's welcomed in
22 and we'll look at how involved he
gets so this is the first one
let me know who you think he will
endorse next
we will have more on the endorsements
and the 2022 campaign on our instagram
which you can find at davidpakmanshow
you can also find me on instagram at
david.pacman we'll take a quick break
and be back with much more
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpakman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
it is great to be joined today by sam
quinones who is author of the new york
times bestseller dreamland the true tale
of america's opiate epidemic and most
recently the least of us true tales of
america and hope in the time of fentanyl
and meth uh sam it's great to have you
one i appreciate it
thank you for having me david good to
good to be with you so i mean just from
just from the titles of the two books
right there's been a change in in uh
what is happening in the united states
as as far as drugs go can you talk a
little bit about i mean how has the
landscape changed from when you were
researching the first book and then now
the second the most recent one
sure of course it it it really has
changed dramatically uh
and quite unexpectedly to me honestly um
when i was writing the first book the
idea was to write the story of how we
had gone from a country that
had uh decided or a medical
establishment that decided decided the
idea was uh a good one to um
massively and excessively in my opinion
um uh prescribed narcotic painkillers
opioid painkillers for all manner of
pain that they had not been used
with uh for before
and and not just that but but like lots
of refills and and kind of under the
with the understanding or the belief
that that these pills would not be at
all addictive to anyone who was a who
was a pain patient that um helped a lot
of people fair to say it also created an
enormous new population of people who
actually were addicted to these pills
were dependent on these bills they they
went to the street uh couldn't find them
very well on the street uh it was very
expensive and eventually they a certain
percentage of those folks um moved on to
uh to to heroin these pills are are have
the drugs in them are very similar to
heroin the underworld um then took over
and that's what led to the next book the
underworld began particularly in the
mexican trafficking world began
providing the heroin um they then
figured out that actually it's a much
better idea to make a synthetic form of
heroin which we now know is fentanyl uh
you don't need any any uh um any any of
the issues that you know land or any of
that kind of stuff and and so the
transformation kind of began
uh
and really about five years ago not long
after dreamland came out you began to
see fentanyl kind of take over and and
now the country is
essentially effectively covered with
fentanyl which is an opioid but of but a
synthetic one you don't make use use
plants to make it and that means that
you can make it uh year-round if you
have the chemicals at the same time
methamphetamine has also now
covered the country because of a new way
of making that as well and so you see
really we're in the era of synthetic
drugs whereas before it was it was the
doctors and uh the classic underworld
providing heroin now it's pretty much
the entire uh source comes from the
underworld and it's now just synthetic
yes in our supply in advance of our
interview i read an article that
the exact name i now don't remember but
it's something like uh can you even
really call it meth anymore and it talks
about how now this this mechanism called
p2p is being used for the manufacture of
meth can you talk about why that's been
so crucial to the dominance of meth
sure that was an excerpt of the book in
fact that that was that was run in the
atlantic
and what what happened with
methamphetamine was interesting years
ago the mexican trafficking world
industrialized the production of meth
using a chemical known as ephedrine
ephedrine is a decongestant you find it
in pseudo-fed pills it's chemically very
similar to meth so you a couple of
tweaks and it turns into meth it's a
it's a kind of a euphoric high very
sociable you want to be around people
you're jabbering away and they made huge
amounts of it but they were always
limited by the amount of of ephedrine
they could get and they could really get
they could get tons of it but it was
really only enough to cover parts of the
western united states never went east
the mississippi river
eventually though the mexican government
got got figured this out and and and
their response was to make ephedrine
essentially illegal except for certain
pharmaceutical companies to produce that
meant that the trafficking world now had
a whole body of knowledge about
methamphetamine and no way to really
make it but there is another way of
making methamphetamine then they began
to
um
figure that out it uses um a precursor
known as as you said p2p phenyl2
propanone
and p2p is actually very messy it stinks
and all that when you turn it into
methamphetamine it does have one benefit
though to detract in the world and that
is that you can make it many many
different ways with the lots of
different uh industrial widely available
industrial chemicals all these chemicals
are legal they're very toxic but you can
if the government cracks down on this
combination of chemicals you can use
this other one and there are many of
these combinations so it allows the
trafficking world
if they can get the chemicals
to produce this stuff in staggering
quantities and essentially that's what's
happening because they have access to
two very large ports and several smaller
ones on the pacific coast of of mexico
through which they get access to the
world chemical markets and they can
bring in all the chemicals that they
like some of these chemicals actually
made in mexico of course and so what you
begin to see it beginning in about 2012
13 is the production of it is just
staggering just unbelievable quantities
of the stuff so much so that it crosses
the mississippi river goes across and
now is up into new england respectively
covering
the country and it's a it's a remarkable
i guess dubious uh achievement but
there's one other thing that that's very
much a part of that story and that is
this
that as this
methamphetamine begins to really march
across the country first on the western
united states in the midwest in 2017 or
so then up into new england 2019 it's
also accompanied
by very severe rapid onset symptoms
of paranoia
uh
and and and hallucinations symptoms of
schizophrenia essentially very intense
paranoia very vivid uh hallucinations
delusions people uh so it's accompanied
by mental illness and very quickly that
mental illness leads lots of people to
be homeless so you see as this meth
marches across the country you also find
big big escalations in the amount of
mental illness and homelessness and
eventually also
uh tent encampments because at 10 these
folks under in this situation in this
condition are not going to be living in
homeless shelters right i want to talk
about that next because there's been a
big this these encampments are a big
topic of political controversy
and i as someone who is you know
unabashedly on the left i consider
myself a progressive the the research
i've done makes me question the wisdom
of the kind of like
let's just leave the encampments because
if we don't have a great place to send
people who are we to take away the one
place that they found and the piece for
me in all of this that makes me hesitate
about taking that approach is
it's not when when you consider the drug
addiction component
there seems to be
zero possibility that folks get out of
that cycle if they remain in the
encampment now breaking up the
encampment raises all sorts of other
questions where do people go is it safe
it's i'm not denying that but it seems
that you have no possibility of drilling
dealing with the drug component if the
encampments stay what's your experience
with that now i would say that
talking with people who work with these
folks and recovering addicts uh as well
i would say that's absolutely true and
it's really actually a little bit more
even serious than that because
talking with folks uh about this um
you very clearly quickly get the the
idea that they're that
the effect of this of this
methamphetamine is really almost at
least semi-permanent
brain damage um it's not like with
ephedrine myth you would stay up for
several days and you would begin to see
kind of shadow people and then you would
sleep it off and you would return to
coherence not that this was good for you
it just was not the damage now now
people are saying and i was just
speaking with a homeless shelter
provider um here in nashville where i'm
now living for for a while
and she was saying that the brain
devastation makes it so that you can't
really teach these folks to function
so the longer they are exposed out on
the street particularly intent
encampments which really exist as
vectors of methamphetamine frequently
even though of course tents were meant
with good intentions
they they they're really kind of a place
now where where meth flows flows freely
that's why they exist because people
it's like the bar where everybody knows
your name in a sense well this is the
same thing and so what what really is
happening is it prolonged exposure to
this is it's very scary and and i've met
people who who've who've recovered from
it and are now sober but they still know
they tell me that several told me this i
still know i'm not the same my brain is
still not fully healed and some of these
folks have been sober a year or two
there's still that paranoia there's
still that slow the memory is really
faded and certainly it takes weeks maybe
even months for the personality of a
person to return so it's the prolonged
exposure in these temp cameras as you
say i think makes it extraordinarily
difficult for those folks to ever
recover
to something close to what they were
beforehand
so uh sometimes you know it's very
popular to talk about portugal when one
talks about drug policy and and
treatment and one of the things that
sometimes folks don't know about
portugal is it's not that in portugal
there's no consequences for drug
addiction it's that they're handled as
health issues rather than criminal
issues but there are consequences there
can be mandated treatment
there people are taken out of the
equivalent of the encampment so to speak
so in thinking about solutions like what
what has worked what or what might work
well i i will i do believe that that
some form of mandated treatment is is
what's necessary here because what
you're looking for in all treatment
you have to come to a point
where you embrace your sobriety where
you embrace recovery the problem is that
that is not possible on the street today
first of all you have fentanyl which
will kill you before you ever develop
any kind of readiness for treatment
right the whole idea you need to be
ready for treatment it's true but the
problem is how do you get there where
did and how long does it take and i and
i think on the street it's very
difficult and within the meth encampment
um
in the meth world it's very hard for
people to first of all in order for
recovery to take place you actually have
to have be able to talk
rationally with other people that it's a
human connection that is essential for
that process to move to move forward and
if you are speaking in what they call in
psychology word salad so the jumbles of
words and
tumbling out of your mouth you know no
idea what people have no idea what
you're saying there's no ability to
develop that deep connection so um first
and foremost detox and prolonged detox
not a few days but weeks
and then an idea that forced treatment
because the drugs
um control is so
um oh profound and that's what a a a
homeless outreach guy told me um
he'd been doing this five years and he
says you know everybody i've offered
treatment to and housing to when i get
them into housing
very quickly they just bolt and they
leave and they run back to the
encampment
so you need to get people away from that
someplace secure some place where they
are mandated treatment some place where
they begin the process the careful
nudging gradual process of coming to
embrace their own sobriety which will
happen but it does need that separation
from yeah that's an important point
which is when when addiction is a factor
just giving homeless folks homes alone
does not actually solve the problem are
there communities in the u.s that are
doing this correctly
i mean i think with methamphetamine it's
so new
um the story really i was i broke this
story in the book and then this in this
thing in the atlantic you know about
methamphetamine and i think many
communities kind of almost didn't know
what they had first of all covid has
kind of overshadowed everything last
year too and then before that the opioid
epidemic overshadowed the meth thing so
people have really not
come to understand the the the deep
issues involved with methamphetamine
some places
uh oh sam we just lost you we first lost
your video and then we lost your audio
now you're back sorry yeah you just
glitched for for a moment there really
yeah but now you're back you're smooth
now
uh okay well um i would say that that a
lot of places have are still trying to
figure this thing out because first of
all i think the opioid epidemic
overshadowed the meth problem and then
also then kovid did the same so what
we're seeing now is people are just kind
of now coming to understand this i would
say that in clarksburg west virginia i
write about in the book several chapters
in the book they tried the housing first
idea and the folks that they put into
housing
destroy there was some refurbished
apartments that they were able to put
them in and and they destroyed the
apartments they they would you know like
a hundred thousand dollars worth of
damage to these apartments there was no
way they could do it so i think people
are just now
i mean really because the story just i
just breaking with this book you know
people are just now become coming to the
point where they're saying let's see if
what we can try i spoke with some with a
with some of a
politician in in northern california who
was thinking um we were talking about
the possibility of using uh empty big
box stores to put a kind of controlled
encampment like put tents but within a
secure big box store controlled entry
and exit and so on and have that be a
place where maybe people detox for the
first but i haven't found anybody who's
been able to deal
um
significantly with this issue that that
this new meth coming out of mexico has
presented over the last several years um
sometimes people will call in and
they'll say hey are you for
legalization of all drugs just like
we're starting to see with cannabis in
some states and you know i i feel very
strongly that decriminalization is
really important and it's
there's a number of reasons why that
seems like an easier thing to think
about and there are good examples from
around the world
when i think about like recreational
meth or recreational heroin these drugs
seem
so
destructive to just one's basic ability
to exist in the world that i i have not
been convinced that recreational
legalization of these makes any sense
how do you conceive of this issue i i i
think not i guess you know i would like
to see here's what i would like to see i
guess first i would like to see us um
legalize marijuana in a mature and adult
way
we are doing it as if you know if it's
if it's a if it's a consumable
um then we need to have those places
inspected
like
food factories are in spa if it's a
medicine we need to have them inspected
like like
factories that produce drugs are are
inspected i think it's absolutely insane
in a time of climate change that we
allow indoor-grown
marijuana a
plant that grows beautifully outdoors we
should that should not be possible and
the idea too
that we are not going to after all never
going to be arresting people for selling
marijuana is is crazy too now you're
seeing dispensaries in california say we
have to compete now with illegal
vendors who don't have to pay taxes or
electricity or rent and all the rest and
and so you need to lower our taxes no
what we need to do is we need a
prolonged ex prolonged time period
probably many years a very aggressive
enforcement of people who are selling
the the drug illegally so that there
won't be that that unfair um competition
for folks who actually have to pay rent
and electricity and taxes and all the
rest that we want for like any liquor
store or any any other place you know to
me this feels like oh and i also believe
that we need to to really question what
the potency should be that we allow for
for commercial for commercial sale it's
it's insane 40 percent thc 90 percent tc
and vapes in this guy i mean and and
these little candy things i mean you
know when joe camel started marketing
cigarettes to kids the entire country
was up in arms and yet it's okay to have
these little gummy bears and all that
kind of stuff to me it feels like and i
think part of this grows from the fact
that we still don't have federal
marijuana legislation and really federal
marijuana legislation needs to put all
of this and much more uh in in into
place but a lot of this stuff seems to
me to be almost juvenile like it doesn't
really matter dude it's just pot well
it's it's not pot it's very potent stuff
and it needs to be treated that way and
we need to approach it like adults
i want to see that done
first and then we can turn our our our
attention to whether other drugs but i
don't really see it happening until we
do this right
no doubt about it the latest book is the
least of us true tales of america and
hope in the time of fentanyl and meth
we've been speaking with the books
author sam quinones sam great having you
on today
love being with you david thanks so much
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies mugs and
t-shirts you can support the show for as
little as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com david pakman
show so i have for you today basically
the perfect example of when democrats
just hurt themselves and make themselves
seem like republicans and make it harder
for voters to want to come out and vote
for them in key elections like the
midterms or 2024 or whenever so this is
what happened and i'm not going to be
unrealistic in my analysis of this and
you'll see what i mean in a second
nancy pelosi was asked during a press
conference yesterday hey what about a
stock trading ban for members of
congress we have all these issues with
members of of congress meaning the house
and senate accused circumstantially in
these conditions where they seem to be
making stock moves
based on things that they know and
everybody else doesn't it's not
technically insider trading
because of the committee memberships etc
that these members have and there's
there's actually an exception where it's
not considered insider trading in some
of these situations although in some you
could argue that it is and it just looks
terrible it makes it seem as though
members of congress are
using information that they learn
through uh their roles as elected
officials supposedly serving the public
to enrich themselves what about a stock
trading ban and nancy pelosi just goes
nah i mean you know we're a capitalist
country you know it's just and it's it's
such a uh uh
even if you're not gonna do it it's the
worst possible response so let's take a
look at the clip and then we'll talk
about it more you should members of
congress and their spouses be banned
from trading individual stocks while
serving in congress no i don't know to
this second one um any uh we have a
responsibility to report
in the stock
on the stock but i don't i'm not
familiar with that five-month review but
if
people aren't reporting they should be
because this is a free market in people
where free market economy they should be
able to participate in that yeah so i
mean listen
like i know nancy pelosi doesn't support
that nancy pelosi is one of the people
along with her husband who regularly
make individual stock trades
options etc and i'm sure it makes them a
whole bunch of money so like i don't
think for a second nancy pelosi at this
point in her career can be convinced to
ban members of the house and senate from
trading in individual stock so i'm not
naive in that sense but this is sort of
like the worst way that you could
possibly answer it and i i know that
why would i encourage politicians to be
dishonest but when i think about winning
when i see this
i think well so are are they different
than republicans or not
the most sort of insidious part
of the house and senate being allowed to
trade individual stocks
it's not just that they can have access
to information that lets them make money
it's they could actually make
legislative decisions to help companies
in which they own stocks or would own
stock so this this is really a very
serious issue so if nancy pelosi just
threw a bone and said hey you know what
i'm just as concerned as you are
we are here to serve the public
we are not here to enrich ourselves and
i am willing to hear any good idea
as to how to prevent
members of the house and senate from
acting inappropriately based on our
privileged positions or whatever and
then say bring me a proposal and then
never do it like in other words i i know
it's not going to happen and so this is
an answer where it's not only that she's
not going to do it she doesn't even seem
to care enough to appear as though it
matters to her that members of the house
and senate not enrich themselves with
stock trades based on information and
then there's sort of like a subsequent
layer as well which is what about the
transparency because there's as was
being mentioned there there's this delay
uh for the reporting of transactions for
members of the house and senate you
could have a much faster
turnaround on that everything is
executed electronically at this point in
time there's no reason for any delay in
the reporting
make a public record immediately of the
trades of the members of the house and
senate and so at the end of the day i
don't have a problem with people making
money we're talking about 535 americans
here 435 in the house 100 in the senate
who are choosing presumably to go into
public service they're not being forced
to do it we're not even saying they
can't make money we're not even saying
they should have to sell all the stocks
that they have just to turn over control
of them i think it's too much to say
you can't buy or sell anything
nothing can be bought or sold in your
name while you're in the house or senate
appoint someone you're not involved in
the day-to-day some call it a blind
trust they can make the decisions for
you so that when you are deciding okay
who do we give a contract to
what kind of regulatory infrastructure
do i push for in this industry or that
but in the back of your mind you know
you own stocks in certain ones of those
industries
at least the stock trading decisions
could be made by somebody else else and
this is the type of thing that makes
people say both sides are terrible
neither side cares about us they just
care about themselves and this is the
stuff that makes me say
democrats are just another party
concerned primarily with
self-preservation in that sense
republican party democratic party it's
basically the same thing
the democratic party has more policy i
agree with certainly and it's such a
small thing
535 people in congress you can't trade
individual stocks
while you're in the house or senate you
could trade mutual funds even though
people don't typically trade them in the
same way you can keep the stocks you had
beforehand just turn over control of
them that's it and uh you know i am not
optimistic
i know that this this is like a
relatively small thing triggering this
reaction but overall i am not super
optimistic about 2022 and i know we have
to still fight for it but i mean you
know
what exactly has been done about white
supremacy and extremism what has been
done on voting rights i guess now they
want to take it up student loans there
was never going to be anything done on
student loans other than make people
start repaying them
uh
something federal on cannabis etc uh
this is a layup at least just give an
answer that looks good i am committed to
making sure and then do nothing she
can't she doesn't even care enough to do
that it's absolutely bonkers and if
democrats lose it
it won't be a shock it won't be a shock
and we will have many explanations as to
why her answer is not the reason why but
it certainly doesn't help
we're continuing to track what's
happening with this omicron variant
and um booster mandates are starting the
united kingdom is setting new records it
is an explosion of information and of
panic and i understand the worry and i
also still don't know that it is
warranted on the basis of what we know
about omicron so let's go through a few
different aspects here
businesses many employers and
universities are now saying
fully vaccinated means three shots not
two
now however serious omicron is the early
data the early data
is that if you have three shots you are
significantly less likely to get a
symptomatic infection of omicron than if
you have two shots now on asymptomatic
we don't yet really know
on effectiveness on against serious uh
illness or death we're still getting
information it seems three shots are
somewhat better but three shots seem
significantly better than two
against omicron
against symptomatic illness so that's
really important so the metropolitan
opera yesterday said
if you want to be an eligible audience
member or an employee you need that
third shot a georgetown nyu some private
colleges have said you're going to need
your third shot number of universities
where i know people uh
working say that when you come back for
the spring semester you've got to have
that third shot the nfl is requiring
coaches and staff to get booster shots
by december 27th and the real question
here
is
what is actually going on
with the omicron variant and i know we
continue to say
it's early we still need more data we
still need to wait it continues to be
that on average if you get the omicron
variant you are less likely to get
really really sick
by virtue of being more contagious which
it appears to be
the burden on society can still be large
and we are seeing even advance of
omicron being the reason even still with
delta we're starting to see
hospitals in different states
increasingly fill up so that's one
aspect of what's going on
um the cdc has issued a forecast that
cases weekly are going to be up to
1.3 million by christmas day
and that deaths are going to surge 73
percent to over 15 000 a week
when and as omicron becomes the dominant
strain and again some people hear that
and they say
well hold on a second um if it's less
serious why would deaths go up and again
you could have something that's half as
serious but three times as contagious
and you would still see deaths go up 50
i mean it's very very crude math it
doesn't exactly work that way but that's
basically the way that it is
in the meantime the uk is seeing
absolutely record cases
a number of different countries are
seeing really really insane numbers
and the good news if there is any in the
uk is that while the cases are going up
dramatically as omicron takes over
deaths due to covid are actually down
over the last two weeks now that may
reverse what what's the what's the
possible counterpoint to
it's very spreadable but less severe the
counterpoint would be
what if there's more of a delay before
you get really sick in other words we i
think at one point the average interval
between infection and death was 17 days
at one point it doesn't really matter
but at one point it was roughly 17 days
is it possible that omicron causes mild
disease for i don't know five weeks
and then you get really sick and die
doctors say it's possible but it's not
very likely so that that's the good news
so far
uh that we can point to
um lastly
the white house there's been this
question of
would the u.s shut down again to the
extent that the u.s ever did shut down
i think the answer is no for for a
couple of different reasons unless there
were to be
a more severe variant which we don't
seem to have at this point in time
number one
at the state level there are very few
states at this point that seem willing
to do anything even remotely
approximating a shutdown that's number
one
uh number two
the white house is saying we are not
going to do that we are not going to
have sweeping
shutdowns um but we are seeing signs
that certainly raise questions as to
what the policy should be the hospital's
becoming overrun events being postponed
some colleges and universities already
going back to remote so there are signs
but the white house insists it's not
going to happen again if you get your
third shot and that actually is 70
effective at preventing symptomatic
illness
and this is a more spreadable but less
serious variant
if people do the right things you
shouldn't have to shut down if the
shutdowns become a real
possibility
um it would overwhelmingly be because a
lot of people aren't doing the things
that are available to us to do let me
know your thoughts what do you think
will happen in the next one to two
months
we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to david p yesterday we covered
the 27 vaccine refusal dismissals in the
air force
and i got an interesting call about that
listen to this
mr pakman sir uh just some quick
uh information on the air force uh
vaccination i'm an air force civilian
and uh you mentioned the 27 service
members that have been discharged so far
just a clarification the
uh those 27 are the ones that not only
refused the vaccine but also did not
apply for a religious or medical
exemption apply for and get important
message too
and so there are still many many many
members in the air force and the other
services that are going through
the exemption process
uh most likely they will all get
declined at which point they will have
to have the same choice that the 27 who
have already been discharged had and uh
will will either have to get out or
uh or get vaccinated yeah that and that
is a good point uh the uh all as far as
i know all branches of the military are
being very strict about these various
exemptions and new recruits are being
forced to sign as a condition of even
starting that they understand they will
be required to get the covid vaccine so
that's a good point the number may go up
it is still quite low we've got a great
bonus show for you today uh it it's not
looking like buildback better is going
to pass this year i i don't know if many
of you will be shocked by that but it's
not going to happen we'll talk about
that a new zealand has a new cigarette
ban that is different than other
countries we will talk about and also
san francisco bay area car break-ins are
on the rise and
some car owners are leaving their trunks
open
um we will explain why on today's bonus
show sign up at joinpackman.com
we will see you then
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
david pakman